بعد ان حصلت الفنانه الشاب عفراء سلطان
على لقب الموسم الثاني من برنامج اكتشاف
المواهب الغنائيه عراق ايضا في موسمه
الثاني
انتجت اغنيتين وفيديو كليب حققوه نجاحا
ونسبه مشاهده كبيره عفراء سلطان كانت تحلم
بالغناء منذ صغرها وكانت تغني بينها وبين
عائلتها وصديقاتها حتى اتيحت لها الفرصه
بالمشاركه والفوز في البرنامج الذي غير
حياتها ومنحها جماهيريه وقربها من الناس
المحبه اهواه في مغنيات قلائل عراقيات
نتحدث عن الجنس النساء صح ما الذي تريد
عفراء ام تضيفه على هذه الدائره
لا شوفي مو مساله انه انا اضيف انت ذكرتي
انه في قلاء خاصه
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله احنا ظهرت عندنا اصوات جديده
لكن انا همم اريد اوصل لشيء كلش حلو ومرضى
تقول ما احد وصلت
واغنيه فيديو كليب نجاح كبير يعني كنت
منتظرها النجاح وشو شعورك
الاغنيه الاولى كانت هي قبل اشارك
بالبرنامج كانت هديه همم
الحمد لله
لا شوفي هو الفنان لازم يكون اا يغني كل
الالوان كذلك اللهجات هذا الشيء يميز انه
يعني تلاحظين مثلا اكون
خاص هسه الاغنيه العراقيه كل الدول التي
تسمعهم مثلا مصر الخليج ااه الجزائر تونس
المغرب يعني
هوايه فلذلك حلو الفنان يغني كل اللهجات
كل اللغات انا ما بدي اشوف ولا بنيه
مكسوره بس حابه اسمع بنيه مكسوره والله
هذه اغنيه قديمه
[موسيقى]
من دنيا
ومن الم
ني والبيه
[موسيقى]
اريد ارتاح
مو مليت
تعبت من المزاجيه
[موسيقى]
اردت
انساك
خير ما يصير
[موسيقى]
وجعود وانت تجيء فيا مني
همم
واحد
في محل